Yeah, hi. My name is Joa, it's an unusual
name, it’s not Joachim, it's just Joa. I
did a lot of flash development back in the
day days but yeah you know flash is dying
all that stuff, so a little bit application
if you need a way to convert it to the web.
So that's why I started building a project
to compile Java bytecode to JavaScript. So
let's have a look at the technology landscape,
what I am talking about today is mostly these
question marks because that's where the magic
happens everything outside is done by different
tools. So we are actually here it takes Java
byte code there are some other solutions as
well, takes Java source code, there's scaler.js
which is tied to scaler compiler, and there's
TVM which is the other project also using
Java bytecode, they all have different subtleties.
Most source code is compiled directly to JavaScript,
only unity is compiling.net, byte code to
SE.js. SE.js we don't do it because its in
Firefox but in general there's some big issue
because there no garbage collection you all
know that Java is like JavaScript language,
and so we leave that on the web assembly I
think this could be a huge opportunity but
whoever is sitting here and implementing it
please remember there's more than C and C++.
Ruby and other implementations. We do everything
ahead of time, so you could also choose to
do this all just-in-time, the difference is
ahead of time means we take the Java byte
code and compare it to JavaScript source code
instead of doing it at run time which means
we could load the byte code in a browser and
while the application is running we could
convert this to JavaScript code, so you could
do it basically if you want to do just-in-time
if you want to executable codes you could
simply create new functions from existing
JavaScript source code you can apply a lot
of different optimisation that we can't apply,
you could make optimistic assumption, here
is a class I know nobody extends this class
so I think that's final, you can reinvalidate
those assumptions which is called the deoptimisation,
you could also support class loaders in Java.
You could at run time define a new class,
load bytecode, do all that at run time. Well,
in fact it's feasible to do it right now because
we have workers now and the problem with the
jet compiling specially in JavaScript would
be that you have all those optimisation and
executing them takes a lot of time, you could
do it in a worker, and if anybody is interested
in doing that I guess it would be a really
interesting project, but we don't do it, we
do ahead of time because we want the browser
to concentrate just on user, because if you
do it just-in-time the browser would have
to optimise your thing that converts to Java
bytecode.
Also Java statistically. Trace and compiler
which will I will explain in a second what
that means, basically it means it goes through
the core graph of the programme, and it also
knows that at this point there isn't a class
extended by a different class. In our case,
because we don't just support JavaScript but
also other platforms it's nicer because as
long as the optimisations are done ahead of
time we don't have to write out in JavaScript
and can apply to all different platforms.
How does the compiler look, what does it do,
I hope you can see that.
I will try to simplify this as much as I could,
but just a quick overview. Basically the compiler
creates a class file, also sorry that I am
talking so fast, but there is a lot of stuff
we have to go through. So, the class file
actually is first it's read by our completer,
what we call completing is reading basically
the byte code which will give us the structure
of the class it fields and methods, although
things can be read as well by our completer,
and every time they are accessed we resolve
those symbols. Which basically means that
the first methods symbol we resolve is the
main function and from there on everything
else is getting resolved.
So, the function goes into code parser which
creates a couple of graphs, at the end it
exports a tree, which is kind of a legacy
thing for us because we just went to a tree
and just the optimiser was going into a special
kind of graph structure, we want to get rid
of this, and do everything on this graph but
right now we are in a tree form. Go through
some generic phases that modify the tree,
and if the optimiser is enabled, we apply
the optimisation if it's not we apply most
of the platform specific phaser that make
the Java code run in the browser as JavaScript
which behaves like Java.
Ok I want to give you maybe a little bit of
an example to understand how this looks. If
you are compiler writing don't spoil the fun
because you will already know what happens.
So that's like a simple method, with a loop,
and it looks quite complex so the first thing
we do is we take the byte code, split it into
graphs so we know what's going on where is
stuff happening, and you can already see it
goes from up here, down into loop and jumps
back and then becomes the exit part and hello,
and you know there are a lot of gotos here
and arbitrary jumps how do you represent those
in JavaScript. Kind of looks like this if
you see you can always do this stuff you can
always do a go to in JavaScript as well. You
can be the first to write that and everybody
will quote you afterwards.
Anyways, from this graph structure we also
build a tree structure that gives you an information
about how is the code actually structured,
where is the loop, how do they follow source
code manner. This is our first estimate of
the JavaScript code, it looks horrible, specially
if you look at the loop, you will always generate
a wide through which has a lot of break and
continue statements, so fast forward like
20 phases, we can always apply a lot of, well
simplify and have you simple loop. This is
what we put it in the optimiser, this is simplified
version of what it sees, again a graph so
we go graph to tree to graph. Which is stupid
but another thing that we have to solve later.
The optimiser, well, does its stuff it has
a lot of knowledge about what's going on,
and as you can see it can get rid of a lot
of stuff, especially in this example. So,
when it gets out of the optimiser we're left
with this little piece which basically says,
well it's here it prints just one. The JavaScript
code we finally generate will look like this
we also do some renaming so it will probably
in the end look like this which is quite nice
for such a big method, and the optimiser can
prove a lot of stuff is unnecessary, so that's
what we want to achieve.
So what's the big problem in all of this?
Semantics. We have to implement all the, JVM
semantics in JavaScript, there's a lot of
stuff here, the lazy - there's no time, lazy
initialisation, and yeah, just quickly want
to explain what all that stuff is. What we
don't want to do is we don't want to add too
much over head that's what making the Java
code in fact run slow and inside of JavaScript.
One thing is the class initialiser. It's always
executed when a class is first been loading
in Java, this where all static variables are
being initialised and all that kind of stuff.
So when you write this kind of code in Java
what actually happens is the base class of
system which is object will get it's initialiser
called then a system class will get it's initialiser
called but any if it's not been called before.
We have to do the same when compiling to JavaScript.
The most simple way to do it you can add a
property to your class, which simply does
all this work and we tried different aspects
of what works best across browsers, this one
where the method is really finding itself
it just returns itself, but that didn't work
out so great performance wise.
In the end this is JavaScript that we generated.
So it's in tight, but there's the problem
because if you run this stuff in a loop, well,
now I would have 10 times for instance this
call to initialiser. And the question is can
we prove that the loop is taken at least once,
because if we can prove this, which we can
of course prove is that we can take the initialiser
out of the loop for instance and apply just
once for a loop so if the loop runs thousand
times we don't have to execute the initialiser
thousand times. This is very important stuff
to do, to make it fly actually you can do
even more you can take the access of the system
out, variable out, of the loop as well, and
pretty good actually you won't notice that
is class initialiser is actually running.
There is another thing, in stance initialisation
where you have a class, all properties like
the x property are initialised with value,
we wanted to do it smart first and we thought,
ok, if you have more than four properties,
I think, then we define the variable for this,
to minify the JavaScript that we output and
then we assign it to those things if you have
50 variables in a class, the code is well,
it's smaller, but the problem is you learn
that JavaScript JMs might guess the size of
your object based on how often they see this.x
= y , not a local variable but this equals
something, so you are back to software one,
the JavaScript - well... make the best guess.
That's like a kind of example of what you
can do.
Numerics are a different thing, in JavaScript
you have a long type, well, already solved
you can basically put it an to an object you
can say I have the high part and the low part
and I too all that stuff and it's quite boring,
what's more interesting is the other simplifications
you can do. For instance if you have a method
like, give me the current time in milliseconds
and it comes to an end. We implement current
and milliseconds on the double, we cast it
back to the long. In fact the method would
look like this, date now, class it to long,
class it to end, you can already see where
it's going, it's probably unnecessary to create
the long. So, we have a method that converts
a double to a long and then we access the
low bits of the long, now we have created
an object that's totally useless. We want
to convert the double into an integer, which
is what happens and saves the long.
So the main story is always simplify, try
to simplify it make it as tight as possible
and give rid of everything that's not totally
necessary.
The integer, first we thought, yeah we love
integers they are really cool, a+ b, simple,
at the ‘on’ operator, the integer is 30,
you need the overflow when you do additional,
multiplication, thank you to AMS.js, we can
use integer multiplication, that's nice, if
you have a double, of course, just - or not.
In fact there is a subtle differences when
you talk about doubles in JavaScript for instance,
if you have a double and apply the or operator
to the non-value, the zero, which is the same
for Java, if you positive infinity, any value
under the maximum integer, JavaScript, well
for positive infinity, JavaScript will give
you zero, if you 'Or', it whereas an Java
you will get the maximum integer, all of a
sudden it's not that simple any more to convert
your double to an integer. We had this little
method written, convert a double to an integer,
which did exactly that. Well, we were quite...
umm... quite an interesting moment because
we had a benchmark and we found around the
benchmark, because it didn't convert a double
correct, we implemented the method and the
benchmark was 10 per second slower, we thought,
the second because we didn't convert the double
correct, you can already see this method is
a little bit stupid, infinity is already greater
than the maximum integer and the negative
is lower than the minimum integer. So we tried
to change this method just a little bit and
all of a sudden we had a 10 frames per second
performance boost, I don't know why the seconds,
but I guess somebody could explain, I guess
it must have to do with the infinity values
that it treats it a little bit different,
but you never know.
So, there is one last thing that we don't
do, but that we will have to do eventually
in the future, it allows you to, well you
divide by zero it throws an exception, which
is crazy, but it does that. Well, in order
to do that you would have to have a method
that checks if it's zero or not and throws
an exception, otherwise you would have to
prove that some value is never zero.
Null point exception, is also quite interesting,
because, I don't know anybody who is doing
that at the moment, basically it means this,
you have maybe a unit test, do some stuff,
you say ok, my tests only pass if null point
exception is raised. So how do you do this
in JavaScript? The most obvious way would
be to say, ok, I simply check if something
is null, right and then I raise an exception,
but it's quite stupid if you have a lot of
changed stuff. You can also go on and say
I'll correct a method that does a null check
for me, but that also doesn't scale very well.
The cruel thing is in JavaScript
you are free to do what you want to do and
you can modify the prototype of type error
to fit into a class system, whenever we see
a type error from the JavaScript, we already
know it's a null point exception and it behaves
like a null point exception, so in our case,
the equivalent, so the extra Java null point
exception is from the perspective of the application
always thrown just when the type error is
thrown.
Last little odd thing, is undefined, because
in Java you don't have undefined, but in JavaScript
you have methods that return undefined and
this is also nothing new but, well what does
this print. It will be false, because undefined
is not strictly equal to null, but it is non--
so if I just have two of those it would be
true. In fact we always want to use strict
equality, because that's more like what the
Java operator would be - so when you too stuff
like this, you would get a weird exception,
because Foo is not now, but it's undefined,
if you just use a strict operator. So you
want to use the non-strict operator, in those
cases where it can be null. Well, it's a little
bit more complicated with strings and all
that's, because this would also cause now,
when you compare a string and an object to
convert your object to a string and we also
don't want to have that, but in fact, when
we implemented this, we got a five times improvement
in a benchmark in Firefox, the only reason
why I could explain that, if you do a strict
equality check that means it's not null, it
means that Firefox, well, you can still be
undefined so I don't know what to do, whereas
where you use a non-strict operator, if you
definitely know that the object is well...
not null or non-defined, maybe there is a
hot path that can be triggered and we were
quite surprised that this actually happened,
I would have thought the strict equality would
be much simpler for a JavaScript engine.
What's the moral of the story? In the end
you want to write, when you generate JavaScript
you should mimic handwritten JavaScript so
to the browser it should always look like
a user has written the code, not a machine
some what translated it. You always have to
clean up and simplify after you, because well,
otherwise all the semantics will slow the
application down. How much time do I have
left? Is there somebody who knows? Nobody
knows. Ten, cool. Yet you should always try
and take short cuts as much as possible, like
with a type error. Use what is available and,
well, you have to test and measure your performance
and I can't stress this enough, it applies
also to everything that you do in normal JavaScript,
which is you have to measure, so when you
apply some optimisations manually, that's,
well, if you don't measure what happens, it
will be quite, yeah... umm... well surprising
results can come out of this.
So, I just have ten minutes so I'll quickly
skip over this, the optimiser, it does everything
you would expect from an optimiser, there
is some cool stuff, so when you write this
in Java, we usually need for the integer the
'Or' operator but we already know it won't
overflow, we don't need the operator and we
can simply use the implement. You can also
prove it in this case where you have the integer
j, which is growing with i, so you would also
not need the operator, but when you are looking
to the sources of the JavaScript JMs you well
figure at they know this stuff but not as
good,
probably because this happens just in time
and they can't spend as much time in all those
analysis. Also we don't do it for the browser,
because the browser, should think it's still
an integer.
This is also quite surprising actually when
you write this in Java, Java will always create
a new string for you and use the - string
concatenation, function what we have to do
for JavaScript, we have to find that there
is a string builder, so we can reconstruct
the JavaScript string concatenation.
This one is one that's actually looks quite
simple on the board, in the slides, but actually
a lot of different optimisations have to play
together, so this is the short iterator in
Java and the compiler in the byte code will
expand it to something like this, while you
have the iterator in the list, while it gets
the next element you get the next element
you write this stuff a lot in Java code it
would be nice to get rid of it, we will generate
this code-based out of it, what has to happen
is the code has to be in lined and you have
to prove the iterator is not escaping the
method, you have to know what values get into
the iterator and what's taken out of, it like
if you have all those 20 things ready, you
are finally pleased with a result like this.
The cool thing is, if you do it in a generic
way it will apply to all of the code that
you insert and that's quite nice. Even if
you write your own list this would happen.
This is much, much easier when you actually
have source code, in source code you just
see the special kind of loop and you know,
oh, ok, I don't, I generate it differently.
So, yeah. That's not so smart in the output.
Last but not least, gene this optimisation,
you can prove that, well, if you like to write
code in a functional style, you can, you can
actually let the compiler transform that back
into a loop, it can know that some stuff is
in a tail position, so we can rewrite it into
a loop, simplify the loop and have a final
result like this.
So, most browsers don't do this, but they
do most of the normal optimisations that you
would expect, actually optimising JavaScript
code by hand isn't necessarily something you
should do these days.
So we compile it to Java, that's what it looks
like, it's basically what all the browsers
use to generate the , Java code
comes out of it, the question is which one
do you use, Blink, Servo, Firefox, they all
have their own with extensions, if you compile
all the web URL and test it in a browser for
once, different browsers you well run to an
enormous amount of inconsistencies, it's just
annoying, yeah.
Workers, it can be quite interesting, the
JavaScript you generate can be directly fed
into a worker, most of the time you can simply
say instead of the window just use the 'Self'
variable, that makes a lot of sense. Also
we were quite surprised we also have to check
for types, if you have some code like things
a worker, instruct mode, you will immediately
get an error like this for some reason error
event isn't defined, you the XML, but not
the error
event, when we have the of check we have to
again rate some stuff like this so it works
immediately in the worker.
That's it mostly for the compiler, I wanted
to talk about the framework around it, the
display list, I did a lot of network back
in the day, what was really cool was that
you had a display list where you could sensory
impairment lie range stuff and move it around,
we wanted to have that too. Basically, I think
that a lot of frameworks that do something
similar, where you have a tree-like structure
and you can arrange all your objects and again
you can apply, like the same ideas that you
use for opt my zing code, to something that
happens at run time. So we don't want to walk
the tree all the time when we render some
stuff to the web, so we want a flat representation,
we do that basically concatenating all the
stuff together in a kind of, well specialised
structure, but in this case we also cache
all the information of the vertices, where
they would go on WebGL, it's quite a thing,
it's what, what an optimiser would do as well,
it has to figure out, does it make sense to
apply an optimisation at the time or not make
sense, we have to render in simply about mode
or put all the stuff to reference cards - oh,
just 2 minutes - I'll just go and, yeah, cache
all the virtual information and - so you get
really fast results. So we rush through the
slides, I wanted to show you some demos from
the display list, I hope it works. In that
case we can see one object is moving, so the
display list would switch, when everything
moves it goes into a rendering stage, it's
nice for applications as well as games. You
get those words.
Just the double thing, ten FPS slower, well,
it uses the infinity thing, so instead of
50 frames, we were at 40 frames. And because
I'm out of time, I just want to show you this
really quickly, we did a lot of the web idea
stuff concatenated it to Java, those guys
that I was working on earlier, converted this
big flash application, audio tool to Java
and then we compiled the Java code to JavaScript
and I hope I've got some internet - but I
don't... well that's too bad. No internet.
Ok, maybe it loads in the end. So, because
when I wanted to show you, this is just a
smaller version of the whole thing and speed
wise we have enough speed now to generate
real time audio and JavaScript and render
all that stuff on the graphics card. So I
can do all this, well tweak a lot of stuff
and it does it all in real time, and so this
is like one of the cool things now that we
have the ability to take the existing stuff
and compile it to JavaScript. There is also
another one, so we also have that in Flash,
that's all now running, it's just pure JavaScript
and it's also at run time parsing all the
mega files, so basically just a load of computations
and you can play your old favourite... yeah...
music. Ok. So let me see if this last... nope...
ah... ok. So the cool thing here is... come
on, come on, this has web artists and live
collaboration. Ok. I talked about the guys
from audio tool they are now all here. You
can say hello. Ok.
>> Hello!
So this application is now running in a browser
and the artists can actually move everything
around, do some stuff so I don't have to do
anything right now, they can make some music,
you have to be quick, I'm already out of time.
So if you know the Flash application this
was actually
quite a big thing, so here we have WebGL,
let's, it's running very smooth and very nice
and I can turn all the knobs, do all the routing
and for me the good thing is to see now that
we basically have this running in the browser
without Flash, it was a big struggle to get
this running in Flash, we implemented our
own garbage collection because the Flash was,
well, bad, so a lot of things to get this
working. . I'm actually not doing anything,
they can all do it in the live collaboration,
which is done by a web artist. You can even
hook the midi stuff to it, it's really brave
it shows the browser is very good at supporting
application that are very demanding when it
comes to resources, it shows you can do what
you want now, we have this timeline here,
which you can - ah, I have to exit this mode.
Ok, so that was something that we never did
in Flash, you can simply adopt the timeline,
so when you have a second monitor you can
now split that application, you can close
it and it flips just right back and this is
well, actually simply amazing. .
Right, thank you. Yeah. So I'm guess I'm done.
Thanks. Thanks for listening. Well, if you
have any questions feel free to come by. Thank
you. . .